[music]
Buber
what
do
you see
?
The whereabouts of a high school girl in Nerima Ward has been unknown
. After she left her home late at night on the 4th of this month, she lost contact with her, and the police suspected that she might have been involved in the incident
.
The first round of one was ignited and I managed to break through, so of course even amateurs can come
anywhere  When I'm pasting it, my mom's why the earthquake happened in Namba
?
I just went to see it, but it was
n't fun.
It took me a minute to get
it.
Please think about the material for the award race, which has increased in number a little more
.  Applause]
[music]
[applause]
ana
toranoana hanan
ani
jalan
ana
tan
5 my everything my everything ani
san
ana
dai
[music]
ana
ani
ni
pane
4 days
both are in
Nerima
Please turn off the radio for a moment I'm thinking about it
Mr. pandan Unten Something interesting happened recently
Interesting thing
do
Time is over
When I'm asked, I'm given about 5 options.It
takes time to think about which one is the best and whether it doesn't hurt
anyone.I think of you.  I'll answer the pad without thinking about anything, so it's probably quick, but you
hurt
me right away Why do you want to hear something interesting
?
I'm having a problem with my friends, so I'm spending time on something that's really useless
.
There's a lot of buzz around it, it's
just that it's laughable, and
then there's the moving system, the refreshing system of judging goodness, and the theory of Japanese gender from a foreigner's point of view.
I don't want to go to the dentist from the seat next to
me if I reveal the truth.
A handsome high school student told me that I was overflowing
with Totomi so much that I wanted to hug him.  I can't hide
it, and I'm going to climb, and I'm going to show my disgust. I can't fake it.
Please take a selfie and take a two-shot with me.
It's better to put mosaics on the driver's face There are
people who don't like this kind of thing
.  I
didn't see this guy, but it's
strange. You're good friends with this guy,
aren't you
?
That's why I'll do it I
'll deliver the room just a little bit
What does it mean that your brother is a good friend when you fly a trillion wanted
cards Hey brother,
you can't believe what that taxi driver says
That's right, but he's a taxi driver, isn't he? He's a hard-to-operate taxi driver.
You have a
proper license, right? You passed the intelligence test at the hall, but
it's in the middle
of the jubako.  I thought I was going to be a
taxi driver.
I'm working with you, so if I say something like that on the public radio
, I'll go home Shut up and get paralyzed with my ability.
On the other hand, a high school girl has
gone missing.  I forgot my cell phone,
you'll be back I'm sure you'll come back Be careful what you forgot
If you listen to this
[music]
r 2
ban
yeah
[music]
[applause]
According to the police, the girls are at 10:00 pm  After talking with his family, he went out late at night. He went
shopping alone at a convenience store near his home, and
after leaving the store, he got into a taxi.  Your mother
has filed a missing person report with the police
Are you happy?
I'm going to the hospital now I'm
going to work, so I'm going to be late
.
I'm going to bed while listening to rakugo, but I'm already a boy.
There's a need for it,
there's only one in circulation in this world Why do you have it?
It's more boring, but
it's just that I can't sleep because I'm so innocent Ah, the minister
, what do
I look like?
I don't know about
rewinding.  I don't need a generation gap appeal Please
,
why don't you get married early
?  I think it's Bruce Springsteen, but I'm sure he
doesn't back down from the stevie wonder of the invention
Springsteen, when you go home, bruce springsteen Bruce Springsteen Bruce Springsty,
Dr.
I
'm waiting for the next patient, so drink up.  Ah, give me some strong medicine You
're going to work now, so don't take it right away I know
what you're doing I got information that you're involved in the disappearance of a high school girl in Nerima
Why are you here?  I went into the house,
it wasn't Mark, so after the fight, I was going to try and force him
to open the car
.
It's just a simple thing, open the door if there
's nothing to be wrong about.
It's an event recording method,
so it's about a
new week,
so
I'm
fishing.  Don't go,
if you go I
don't know, but I don't know if you're a wanted criminal with a pistol
.  Umbrellas that will be cleaned from society's point of view I'll
try borrowing a nice shop style Nails like me I just prefer younger ones
What do you take?
]
[Music]
Hmmm
Good job perl Sensei
Beer Jodai a
[Music]
[Applause]
How's the Mahayana gear?
It's a sign
I hope you guys will persuade me too
I wonder if it's a big hospital decision Something
's wrong
Pooh
Don't you think it's weird?
No, it's distorted Yeah, it's
something more fundamental
.  He said he went to ask a neighbor
about it, and then he heard a voice talking to someone in an audio car that was supposed to be living alone
.
Momo knows what's so bad about
being drunk and rampaging in a club.
I'm not sure if I
'm serious about the trend of killing people like biotechnology is the only way to go, but I don't
want to get involved either way, that's ridiculous  I can't believe
the story, but it's really just this story
, it won't hurt me, so it's okay to be honest with me, but if you give in to someone, you're a woman.
It's a gift of ability, so it's okay Wow font re I
don't know Ahhh Nuuuuu brother You're saying something obvious like the three non-nuclear principles
Wudu
I don't know how long it's been, but it's been decreasing today.
So you're the only alpaca What's going on?
Take me on a mission Panmy The bases are loaded a little bit on a regular basis I know what you want is water Hey,
each scene is a Mercy pot Super big spy and lying lines I don't feel anymore
So [music] ana me nan car n ame nan good good good good
ana
amaran ok ok ok
Taxi drivers will sell to the people in the shops,
right? Cute things will come on board, right?